all right well I guess I'll start I'll
start chatting we got a couple people
kind of showing up we got some a little
bit undertale music in the background
and tell me like as always let me know
if the the audio is kind of obnoxiously
loud or if it's if it's unbalanced I
think I got it about right I I guessed I
did my usual guessing game and I feel I
feel like I nailed it because I think
I'm awesome
so yeah that's definitely definitely
where where I consider myself to be so
hello Noel hello hello mote man Merry
Christmas Happy Holidays
whatever whatever holidays you may or
may not observe thanks for thanks for
stopping by I'm gonna talk a little bit
now there's it here's a way that I'll
cover a little bit of time here as as a
couple people sort of roll in and they
just explain a little bit of what what
I'm doing here or why I'm doing this
because it's like why why on Christmas
Eve why Dan why on Christmas Eve would
you choose to stream undertale rather
than spend time with with friends and
family because I certainly do do you
have that option I could be I could be
out though most of my family is out of
town I've got some so friends I could
stay with but I thought I thought I
would do this because it's important to
me from my childhood
and let me explain why why I say that
what what is important to what about it
is important to me from my childhood
well growing up my dad was in radio he
he was on air sometimes he was so so
every but he worked a lot in in like the
managerial side but he was also on air
like when I was a really little kid he
was on air and also like even within the
managerial side sometimes on holidays he
would have to fill in and so usually
about every two or three years dad would
end up
working on New Year's Eve for Christmas
Eve or New Year's Day or you know so
there would be these times where he
wasn't around because he would be at the
station doing the on-air stuff for for
that time and so we wouldn't on those
years we would listen to the radio as we
were doing our Christmas Eve stuff
because then you know that there's dad
there's dad on the radio and so it it
became meaningful to me the connection
that you could have with people over
over a broadcast that you didn't
necessarily like that was a way of
connecting with people and so even on
the years where we didn't where dad was
with us we would still often have the
radio station that he was working at we
would have it playing around the house
so that we you know would have a little
bit of that connection to to the DJ that
that in in some way by listening to them
they weren't then alone at the station
even though they were like they were
physically alone at the station and they
didn't have you know a chat room that
they could back and forth with but they
would try and establish you know rapport
with the with the listeners and and it
struck me that there was a way of having
some human connection through the
intangibility of a broadcast and so I I
thought that now with with new media
with changing media here we are on New
Year's Eve and I would follow a little
bit in in my dad's footsteps and and
broadcast for all those who were sitting
at home who maybe don't have anywhere to
go who maybe just are are being
themselves and just enjoying themselves
staying in it's not that they don't have
anywhere to go it's that they are where
they want to be but you know giving it's
it's a chance to to connect with people
it's a chance to to keep you company and
have you keep me company and I thought
what better way what an absolutely
better way
of celebrating that or or engaging with
that than a pacifism run in under health
I thought that was quite quite
thematically wonderful way of doing it
so we we are here to be a friend to
monsters and dogs and and yeah so thank
you all for thank you all for coming out
and I hope I hope you enjoy and we'll
we'll keep each other company and it
will be good and we will have a happy
holidays so I actually started the game
a couple days ago I actually I hadn't I
have not played this all the way through
before I just picked it up with the
Steam sale earlier this week and I
started it a couple days ago but then in
order to do the broadcast I needed to
switch over to a different partition
which didn't bring my save game with me
so we'll actually be starting all the
way over from the beginning and hello
suddenly senpai senpai welcome welcome
to the stream and here we are so we'll
be starting over from the beginning and
this will be a full passivism run I will
probably die more than once because I am
bad at video games
it turns out I have learned that
streaming that I am I am bad at video
games and I should probably give up but
I won't I won't give up and you know
what let's let's go whoo-hoo so we are
gonna be Santa we're gonna be Santa
that's who we're gonna be we're Santa
because that is only appropriate all
told is this name correct
yes yes we are Santa so I have played
through the first two hours or so but
but past that past that it's all new to
me so I already know about I already
know about this this is such a OH
this tutorial is so good it's so good
it's it's heartbreaking
no you though I just went through it a
couple days ago it's still it's still
just like I still feel betrayed I know
it's coming but I still feel betrayed
toriel
I'm using the keyboard I wanted to use a
game actually but
I now one of the things actually going
into it so I I haven't actually had most
of the game spoil for me in fact what I
kind of considered to be the spoilers I
had been exposed to it turns out they're
not so the whole elements of of being
able to talk to things and the whole
idea of a pacifism run
I was I was initially assuming that like
oh okay well that's you know the
importance of it
was something that I thought was you
know possibly spoilers but then you get
into it and it's like no it basically
lays that all out like right away you
know so so I was afraid of that that
maybe I had had that element spoil or
the significance of that spoil but I
happens
you know toriel starts off right away
just being like okay here's here's the
deal
you might want to do this and then they
really push they do push that or they
they press the possibility of it and the
significance of it more or less right
away and I
I don't know how much I know anymore
that's all been cast into cast into
doubt also I realized just like
yesterday that other things that I
thought might be it's like kind of
spoilery or actually just back of the
box stuff like it's right there in the
steam description which I've actually
never read so I probably know virtually
nothing about this game relative to
people who have actually been properly
paying attention people who have been
certainly people that play it know far
far more than and I'm excited too I
really like I like the impact that it's
had on me so far I like mechanics I
enjoy that the I did not leave you I was
merely behind this pillar the whole time
toriel
I really like where they went with the
pacifism mechanics and how
it's it's not just a one-note thing then
they have turned like that they have
made it a suitable suitable challenge
and that there's actually a lot of
really interesting mini mini puzzles in
order to in order to progress my my
favorite so far has been it's about an
hour in it's these two dogs with with
giant cleavers giant axes two dogs with
giant axes and you have to roll on the
ground in order to disguise your sense
as a dog and then you pet them and their
doggy Minds there their minds are blown
because they had never before considered
that a dog could pet another dog it's so
good it's it's some great kind of
throwback to the really sort of them
like the moon logic of old
fold what am I trying to say
adventure games like Hitchhiker's Guide
to the galaxy and whatnot it has that
kind of sensibility to it in a lot of in
a lot of great ways you know what do you
do you you compliment the Frog but it
doesn't understand but still
also senator butterscotch
which which do we prefer cinnamon or
butterscotch cinnamon or butterscotch I
went with butter I'm gonna go with
butterscotch
I like butterscotch I know yeah
butterscotch oh I see you do not dislike
sitting and do you know what your
preference is but would you turn up your
nose and my heart
and oh I just caught that I just caught
that all right all right you don't
sorry I just got that okay so the sign
says three out of four three out of four
gray rocks recommend you push them and
then the fourth grade rock that you come
across yeah
let's see if I can nail this oh yeah oh
yeah our guy great memory apparently
apparently I have a good enough memory
so one Rock and now we've got three
rocks so that makes four rocks total
target in a wins them wins them won't
even try so I can just compliment frog
frog it
so three and the fourth Rock
three out of four rocks recommend you
push them and the fourth you need to
convince you don't you don't actually
you convince it to move like that's just
oh that's it's very it's so subtle and
it's just wonderful ghost
sorry ghost
you gotta just keep cheering
yeah
a dapper bro do you like it oh wait I
don't but I do have enough and you have
enough for the
I don't have enough I can't
sorry spiders
I can't buy anything from the spider
bake sale unless this looks
there we go
now I've got enough
yay spider donut check looks and then
say his full name out okay
check looks and sees full name out that
alright hello toriel
this one with the carrot yes
this one took me a while the misted
eat my greens all right or just got it
ah no
oh you're all talking about that deep
spoilers it seems alright Marines
ie I know last time I was playing wait
did I not hit the search did I forget to
hit the switch if I go through all that
and then forget me once which I did
this puzzle I thought was great
I'm gonna kind of blow through a bunch
of these just Chris you know I already
freaked about I already did him a couple
days ago and I don't think I don't think
he'll all mind too much it is apparently
a fairly long game so
Oh
laughing switch
it's only like five to seven hours okay
I thought it was I thought it was a
little bit longer like closer to 14 but
that might have been people who like
really really dug into it
like I said I'm not always the best the
bullet-hell the bullet-hell aspect is
actually I'm not very good at nope dang
it yeah red is closest to that's okay
that's all right wait did it say bed
let's head red right press the green
switch looks don't pick up I walk her
looks I Walker
okay yeah please don't pick on me ah ah
oh yeah yeah
got it
there we go
three or four playthroughs to see all
the content
it's joy good to know
there we go hello toriel i love
tutorials voice it's just it's kind of
perfect for something that's so low res
I just got seven
and then they don't interest you at all
as great as Arceus is pretty lousy it
means
get the chocolate bar in case I need to
heal later because I'm bad and I'm
terrible this is heartbreaking I know
what happens but still I'm going to
destroy it
keep good child and go upstairs and you
assert yourself no I totally get where
you're coming from tutorial how you
understand but I can't